if you were online this weekend chances
are you saw this story about a couple in
Mississippi that was trying to conceive
a child through IVF but when they got
their blood test results back it turned
out they were twins
normally a brother and sister trying to
get pregnant Mississippi would not be
any kind of a news story but it is
because it's fake fake news fake news
even the mirror in the UK reported on it
this was proven to be fake news but
people are still spreading it around
cuz no one can reads anymore or thinks
about things or gives it about what
really is going on too much data TL DR
we're just like chicken just pressing
share and like buttons just pecking out
with a little chicken beak for food but
you know but instead of any kind of food
with any kind of nutritional value we
just get a brief but intense blast of
dopamine which lasts about four seconds
until you know we snap back into it
because someone called us Hardwick
on but all right I'm ready so comedians
what are some ways you could tell the
person you are about to marry is your
twin Adam the same dude walks both of
you down the aisle
alright
seventy-five you need to get a wedding
dress that downplays the liver kidney
and aorta that you share all right yes
that's James David when one of you is
Ashley Olsen and the other one murdered
Heath Ledger
[Applause]